what's the next big porn category step
chickens there no there's a I saw some
post about a device broke it it can
simulate tastes of food and and other
things and and smells No
yeah on your tongue oh yeah yeah that's
what's gonna be one if Paltrow's gonna
have a field day would that [ __ ] bro you
wife comes home her husband it just has
like it's like a stick that you put on
your tongue it's very obvious and he's
just like on a large this is a [ __ ]
80 inch television
just leave some [ __ ] video just got
the stick on his tongue he's like oh oh
how did that get there
it's a pixie stick is I didn't knows no
it's just no good to get the smell you
to put it on your tongue so you taste
the smell it was something like that let
me get that the actual quote huh just
talking like that full from rat-race
with the pierced tongue oh my god and
forever since I've thought about that
rat race what a movie well oh the noron
Mackie synthesizer is a lickable screen
it's a screen that can recreate almost
any taste
oh sorry or flavor sorry no smell
without eating food smell would be funny
if I had a little like vents on the side
smell-a-vision pump up this like gasps
oh it just smells like whatever you're
like it you know you're watching a
cooking video yeah or a fart noise oh
they're a fart
but YouTube YouTube videos this video is
nor Mansky synthesized oh yes oh I love
this video it tastes like meat oh my god
wife comes home do is watching porn just
lapping the screen cat drinking milk
[Laughter]
it's a close-up shot of a [ __ ] that's
[Music]
that's gonna be you know that's the
future of memes someone sends you a dope
noir Manske synthesizer [ __ ] lick video
and you start washing in you're licking
your your synthesizer and then it just
changes to dick all of a sudden out of
that dick taste dude we talked about I I
turn it off before you know you got
there before I even got there you start
having a pumpkin meltdown crying and
[ __ ] texting your wife I've heard you're
gay what what Justin sent me a meme and
I was tasting it and then it chased you
thank you so I taste the dick Justin
sent me of me when I was tasting it
I swear - me too but I tasted the dick
and what I like - dick I tasted it well
how could I have an or Manske
synthesizer when did you buy that for
tasty memes it just started as a joke I
watch you know the crafty videos and
taste the macaroni and it just it was
supposed to give drugs watching those
cooking videos I thought it'd be nice if
you could taste the Instagram cooking
video and then I thought I'd give it a
try before I sent it gave it to you and
then they lick the penis that's good
what takes a dick anymore
- you imagine tasty accounts and it's
just pictures of [ __ ] and it's all video
just sitting on your phone in public
with your [ __ ] put that [ __ ] steak
just just yeah go I sorbet ice cream
okay peanut butter cookie you just go to
some corporate coffee shop and they're
all just like ear to ear with the
[ __ ] stick on their tongue eating a
[ __ ] eating a gut down Amazon
Microsoft [ __ ] cheeseburger green
bean Amazon smoothie infused with
Microsoft flavours even with the steak
Jesus dude [ __ ] so funny
tasty memes some tasty meme
you